النيران الصديقه روايه يتداولها مدونين
عسكريون مؤيدون للكرملين حول الطائرات
الروسيه التي اسقطت في سماء اوكرانيا طبعا
هؤلاء يزعمون ان كل الطائرات الروسيه
تقريبا والتي تم اسقاطها عمليات وقعت
بالخطا بواسطه انظمه الدفاع الجوي
لموسكو نفسها فهل فعلا انظمه الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه باتت العدو الاول والابرز
لسلاح الجو الروسي في خانه ما وصف
بالنيران طبعا الصديقه اكد العسكريون
الروس ان قواتهم فشلت احيانا في التفاعل
وابقاء التواصل ما بين فروعها ما ادى الى
سقوط طائرات مقاتله من طراز السوق 34 سوء
بالاضافه الى ايضا مروحيات 52 كي همم
وبالفعل اصدرت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بيانات عده على مدى الاشهر الماضيه اكدت
فيها ان روسيا اسقطت بعد طائراتها بالخطا
اخرها الاسبوع الماضي علما بان موقع
اوريكس الذي يتتبع الخسائر على الجانبين
اكد فقدان 63 طائره روسيه وما يمثلها عددا
من المروحيات اما هيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه فحددت خسائر
موسكو من طائرات الهليكوبتر
ب268 طائره والمقاتلات نتحدث عن 200 و 283
طائره حربيه منذ بدايه الحرب في فبراير
الماضي بحسب تقرير صادر عن معهد بريطاني
فان النيران الصديقه هي واحده من اكبر
المشاكل التي قودت العمليه العسكريه
لروسيا في اوكرانيا وعنوانها الابرز طبعا
الافتقار الملحوظ للاتصالات
[موسيقى]